مرحله جديده من التوتر في مضيق تايوان
مناورات عسكريه صينيه بذخيره الحيه تشمل
للمره الاولى تدريبات على تطبيق تايوان
بالكامل وتحاكي ضرب اهداف رئيسيه في
الجزيره مناورات السيف المشترك تضمنت نشر
عشرات الطائرات لفرض حصار جوي على الجزيره
بمشاركه حاملات الطائرات شاندوغ وتشمل
المناورات العسكريه ايضا مشاركه مدمرات
وزوارقه سريعه قاذفه للصواريخ ومقاتلات
وطائرات تمويل واجهزه تشويش تصعد دفع
السلطات في تايوان لرفع حاله التاهب
نيه لتصعيد الموقف ستحافظ قواتنا على
سيادتنا وامننا القومي بطريقه رصينه
وعقلانيه ومدروسه في غضون ذلك ظلت وحدات
دفاعنا الجوي في حاله تاهب قصوى انهم
يراقبون عن كثب كل هدف محتمل ويستجيبون
لحاله الطوارئ
الخارجيه الصينيه بررت تدريباتها العسكريه
المستمره منذ ثلاثه ايام بانها رساله
تحذير للانفصاليين المتواطئين مع قوى
خارجيه بحسب وصف الوزاره الولايات المتحده
لم تكتفي بمراقبه الوضع بل ارسلت المدمره
ميليوس لتبحر في منطقه في بحر الصين
الجنوبي تطالب بها بكين وهو ما دفع بكين
للاحتجاج توتر المنطقه وتطور الاحداث دفعه
مركز الرؤى التخصصيه العالمي في هارت فورد
الامريكيه الى رسم ثلاثه سيناريوهات
المحتمله لكيفيه اعاده توحيد الصين مع
تايوان الاول عبر ما اسمعه بالغزو الصيني
المباشر لتايوان والثاني من خلال الحصار
البحري والجوي في مرتبه السيناريو الاخير
بتغيير سياسه التايوانيه على غرار ما
فعلته بكين في هونج كونج حنان المصري
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات